hoy vamos a modificar la cámara digital
tenemos dos botones uno es el botón de
encendido y el otro es el botón de
disparo primero tenemos que oprimir el
botón de encendido y luego el botón de
disparo para poder tomar fotos
les quitamos las cubiertas y al hacerlo
vemos que las conexiones son muy
pequeñas y va a ser difícil de soldar
queremos conectar con estos cuatro
puntos atrás que son los que conectan
los botones con el circuito de la cámara
quitamos estos interruptores
lo primero que tenemos que hacer es
proporcionar energía eléctrica a la
cámara así que tenemos que ver cómo
lograrlo vamos a intentar usar nuestras
baterías en bits y bot así que vamos a
soldar un cable en la terminal positiva
ya que es aquí en donde conectaremos
nuestra batería y para esto usamos y
soldamos 'nuestro cable de calibre 22 y
como es la terminal positiva ponemos
cable rojo que es el que simboliza esta
terminal si vemos la parte de atrás nos
damos cuenta de cómo están cableadas las
baterías de la cámara y ahora vamos a
soldar el cable de tierra en la terminal
negativa así que aquí soldamos nuestro
cable negro de calibre 22
una vez que hagamos pasar los 5 voltios
por estos cables podremos encender
nuestra cámara basicamente extendimos la
conexión en donde normalmente tendríamos
nuestras baterías para cablear nuestros
interruptores de encendido y de disparo
vamos a necesitar cables muy pequeños
muy delgados estos me parece que son
cables magnéticos de calibre 38
y justo ahora les estamos quitando el
aislante al extremo de este cable el
aislante está lacado así que raspar
hemos el aislante para poder soldar el
cable vamos a pegar el cable con uno de
nuestros contactos y nos va a ayudar a
sostener el cable en su lugar una de las
razones por la que usamos un cable tan
pequeño es para que cuando le pongamos
la soldadura y ésta fluya alrededor del
cable no ocupe tanto espacio como para
que toque otro componente o contacto que
necesitemos mantener por separado para
que todo funcione vamos a calentar un
poco este cable para soldar lo y será
más sencillo poner un punto pequeño de
soldadura si tienen una punta más
pequeña en su cautín el que tengo aquí
es demasiado grande ponemos un poquito
de soldadura y dejamos que cubra el
cable y haga una buena conexión hacemos
esto para nuestro segundo cable y
nuestro tercer cable aquí está el tercer
cable y lo ponemos en su lugar es muy
importante que estos cables permanezcan
separados y no se toquen o conecten
entre sí pues de otra forma el
interruptor no va a funcionar finalmente
hacemos lo mismo para el cuarto cable y
se necesita de mucho
práctica para poner la cantidad exacta
de soldadura para hacer la conexión pero
no demasiada como para que toque otra
conexión si no tienen mucha experiencia
usando el cautín y la soldadura les
recomiendo que practiquen bastante antes
de realizar estas conexiones ahora que
ya tenemos conectados nuestros cables
vamos a pegarlos para asegurarnos de que
permanezcan en su lugar lo cual es
importante porque nuestras soldaduras no
son muy fuertes y si jalamos el cable la
soldadura se desprenderá y arruinará
nuestra conexión aquí vemos nuestro
controlador de el motor y aquí vamos a
conectar el cable negativo de nuestra
cámara al cable negativo de nuestro
controlador del motor y también vamos a
conectar el cable negativo de las
baterías aquí en la misma terminal que
es el pin que está a la izquierda del
bloque central ahora conectaremos el pin
terminal de la derecha al cable positivo
de la batería que es el cable de 12
volts positivo lo conectamos en el pin
de la derecha
y lo atornillados y pueden ver que al
hacerlo se soltó el cable negro y
tenemos que colocarlo de nuevo
ahora tomamos el cable positivo de
nuestra cámara después que recolectamos
el cable de la batería el cable positivo
de nuestra cámara en el pin central que
es nuestra salida de 5 volts de manera
que tengamos 5 votos para encender
nuestra cámara
aquí tenemos nuestro voltímetro la
energía pasa de nuestras baterías hacia
nuestro controlador del motor pasa por
el chip central que es un chip regulador
de 5 volts así que convierte en nuestros
12 volts a 5 volts ponemos nuestro
voltímetro en el pin negativo y en el
del centro y vemos que tenemos un
voltaje de 4.98 volts por lo que tenemos
la cantidad adecuada de voltaje para
nuestra cámara también revisamos que el
voltaje que llega a nuestra cámara es el
adecuado y está en el lugar correcto y
resulta que también tenemos 4.98 volts
en la cámara
es más de lo que necesitamos para
nuestra cámara pero creo que estamos en
el rango tenemos el voltaje que
necesitamos ahora tenemos dos cables
aquí son dos de los cables que
conectamos y vamos a ver si nos sirven
para encender la cámara si encontramos
los cables correctos y los conectamos
deberemos poder encender la cámara y
veremos que se enciende la pantalla lcd
veamos si podemos lograr que esto suceda
y si funciona estos son nuestros cables
de encendido y permiten que la energía
fluya en nuestra cámara ahora si
queremos tomar una foto deberemos
conectar los cables de disparo hoy y lo
que vieron que pasó es que ambos cables
tocaron el metal de nuestro l 298 lo que
hizo que se conectarán así que es
importante evitar que esto suceda así
que hay que mantenerlos separados para
que no se toquen cuando no queramos
ahora si tomamos nuestros cables de
disparo y acabamos de tomar una foto a
continuación vamos a cablear un circuito
para que nuestro arduino pueda controlar
cuando esto suceda cuando ocurre el
disparo cuando la cámara está encendida
ya que tenemos separados los cables
podremos colocarlos en un circuito con
nuestro arduino